Jonathan I definitely have to ask you um
you know I'm a fan of uh of these Marvel
films and I'm just curious I know you're
not going to tell me anything about the
future but what is it like being part of
a universe where you are going to be
such a central character for the next
few years like a it's a guaranteed gig
but B it is like I mean you are a very
big Focus um and I'm just curious what
it's like for you
are you excited by it is it you know
well it's funny man we were coming in
here and a bunch of guys who you know
like like some movies and and a lot of
them like the the MCU movies
um
is exciting the fact that
think about theater right you do a play
you have no idea if someone's coming to
that show yeah I mean you work your ass
off you have no idea like okay the
tickets don't really matter you know you
never check into different ecosystem you
know you're hoping people are going to
come see the work you've done in that
space in that black box for that long
right you're hoping it's going to happen
um with the MCU you know and and with
Kang
um there is such a
a beautiful
sensation knowing that uh the work that
myself and my collaborators do
um is going to reach people
um that responsibility
um is something I honor and something I
I really take on you know
um
there's 50 guys outside all those all
those guys are going to see you know uh
quanta Mania you know what I mean
that's beautiful you know what I mean
like that a guaranteed impact you know
is something that you go okay yeah you
know but no I was going to say one of
the things though and I could be wrong
is that you're playing the same
character but it could be versions of
the same character so you're not
possibly the same I don't know actually
I mean as an actor I mean like no no
spoilers here like like uh Kang Kang has
we can take it there uh but Kang has
variants you know I mean
um
there's you know there's always variance
um I I I'm King so whatever comes
through comes through you know what I
mean and uh
yeah it's neat well one of the one of
the things though and and like people
don't really talk about it but like a
movie like this magazine dreams there's
gonna be people that are Marvel fans
that are going to seek this movie out
specifically because they've seen you in
a Marvel movie and they want to see you
know or someone saw you until or uh
swallow and said oh I want to see her
next movie so I mean can you you know
what I mean like that's obviously not a
reason you cast Jonathan but it's an
added benefit that more people will see
it yeah it doesn't hurt at all it really
but it it it's great because I think it
will bring more eyeballs to a movie that
otherwise might not have been seen
um with that said it it is not the
reason I cast either of them I cast them
because I think they were just perfect
for the roles that we wrote and I think
they embodied
um the spirit of the character and their
actors I had been wanting to work with
and was grateful to work with and the
fact that they now have like these big
franchises that are bringing attention
to them
all the better but um I mean that's the
beauty of that came from that's to be
about Sundance about independent film
and about uh
I mean what you and I do as as being in
front of the camera you know that like
having having either one of us in the
film at whatever point in our career
then brings people to a different type
of story you know what I mean
um that's beautiful that then helps us
tell similar stories like you know a
magazine dream you know
um with from other points of view other
Vantage points if you if you get folks
you know that have I mean it's also a
different muscle to be honest yeah I
mean like
the speed of it it's different yeah I
mean the intensity of it can be
different you know unless you hold it
steady you know
um
but yeah that's
I'm rambling but it's a
yes I am rambling
no it's true you know you you have
infinite amount of days making a mobile
film and you have 24 days to make
magazine dreams and 18 days to make
swallow like it's a different beat it's
it's all beautiful
um but yeah it takes different different
muscles